what is that like complex systems
emergencies what is that will that ever
be understood by science so here's
here's the way that i think about it so
there are
clearly qualities of the world that
emerge on macroscopic scales
our sense of beauty wonder consciousness
all these kinds of qualities
do i feel that they ultimately are
explainable
from the laws of physics i do
there is nothing that's not ultimately
ultimately explainable with the laws of
physics from this physicalist
perspective which is what i take
so
you got the particles you got the laws
and you have things that emerge from the
choreographed motions of those particles
but is that the best language for
talking about these emergent qualities
usually not
if i was to
take something even more mundane like a
baseball flying through the air if i was
to describe it in terms of the quarks
and the electrons i'd give you this
mountain of data with you know 10 to the
28 particles and all of their
coordinates in space as a function of
time i hand you this mountain of data be
like i don't know what this is
and then if you really were clever
you're looking oh it's a baseball just
described in the in the least economical
way possible it is much more useful and
insightful to talk about the baseball
flying through the air similarly there
are things at the macroscopic level like
human experience and human emotion and
human action and the sensation of free
will that we undeniably all have even if
it itself doesn't have a basis in our
understanding of the physical world it's
useful to talk about things in this very
human
language and so yes it's vital to talk
about things in the poetic language of
human experience but do not lose sight
of the fact and some people do they say
oh it's just an emergent phenomenon
don't lose sight of the fact that
emergent phenomena are emerging
from this deeper understanding that
comes from the reductionist account of
physical law and there's a lot of
insight to come from that such as
the freedom that you thought that you
had the freedom of will that you thought
you had it doesn't have a basis in that
reductionist account so it's not real
you